Just 4 months ago this professional
tennis player only had €900 in his bank
account but now that he's made it to the
second round of the Australian Open he's
thrown a couple more zeros to that
number Sumit Nagle made over €100,000
after he beat number 31 ranked Alexander
bub just for making it to the second
round of the tournament if Sumit is able
to secure a win in the second round
he'll be able to tack on another
$121,000 to his bank account not only is
the money an incredible bonus of making
it to the second round but winning also
made Sumit the first Indian to beat a
cedon since 1989 he said he had no idea
about that but that he's just trying to
enjoy the moment now because these
moments don't last forever he's hoping
that this feat will improve the tennis
culture in India he doesn't feel like
Indian Pros should have to leave India
in order to get a real chance he said it
would be easier for pros to make it if
there were more tournaments coaches and
better facilities in India